Transcriptor: Jorgelina Pignoni
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Hola, yo soy Perrozompopo,
un cantautor de Nicaragua y agradecidísimo
con esta invitación de TEDxPuraVida,
aquí en San José, Costa Rica.
Voy a interpretarles un par de canciones.
La primera se llama Y Sería el Aire,
que es una canción que está
en mi último disco titulado Árbol.
Espero que la disfruten.
Cuando se va de tu cintura caminando,
todas las cosas flotan,
suavecito en ese andar.
Todo se vuelve tan liviano, tan bonito,
como el andar de tu cintura al caminar.
Podría volver a besarte otra vez.
Diría tu nombre.
Y sin miedo otra vez
abriría todas, todititas mis ventanas.
Y sería el aire.
Y sería el aire que perfuma el corazón.
El corazón.
Cuando llevas algunas flores en el pelo,
y vas andando sobre la orilla del mar,
se me enamora el corazón
por la hermosura de la sonrisa
que me dejas al pasar.
Podría volver a besarte otra vez.
Diría tu nombre.
Y sin miedo otra vez
abriría todas, todititas mis ventanas
Y sería el aire.
Y sería el aire que perfuma.
Podría volver a besarte otra vez.
Diría tu nombre.
Y sin miedo otra vez
abriría todas, todititas mis ventanas.
Y sería el aire.
Y sería el aire que perfuma el corazón.
El corazón.
Dejó caer en mi arena
sus pies.
Dejó saber en mis labios
su sed.
Juntos probamos la noche.
El suave murmullo del imán y la flor.
Fuimos casi un muro,
casi viento, casi sal.
Fuimos casi nada y todo de una sola vez,
de una sola vez, de una sola vez.
Y nos quedamos ahí,
como bordando el dolor,
como sacando del mar
el rostro para llorar.
Y nos quedamos ahí,
con la certeza de estar enredados
entre remolinos y su amor.
Y su amor.
Los dedos iban tanteando
entre piel y piel.
Era el reconocimiento
de sudores de su nombre.
Y fuimos casi un muro,
casi viento, casi sal.
Fuimos casi nada y todo de una sola vez,
de una sola vez, de una sola vez.
Y nos quedamos ahí,
como bordando el dolor,
como sacando del mar
el rostro para llorar.
Y nos quedamos ahí
con la certeza de estar enredados
entre remolinos y su amor.
Y su amor.
Y nos quedamos ahí,
como bordando el dolor,
como sacando del mar
el rostro para llorar.
Nos quedamos ahí
con la certeza de estar enredados
entre remolinos y su amor.
Y su amor.